[Music]
this is a series about long-term
thinking and what's been especially fun
about it is to talk to speakers and get
them engaged and they then realize that
what they're doing actually has a
long-term thinking aspect to it now it
is the case here that one of our
actually our first sponsor will Hearst
who was here and will join Chris on the
stage I said you know this is really a
time dimension to this and he'll tell
you something about what he thinks about
that tonight so called Chris said
there's a time dimension he said yeah I
know and so we got into exploring it
further and so this talk in anticipation
just a month or so of his book the long
tail which is coming out is part of
expanding what has turned out to be an
extremely powerful idea one of those
ideas that will probably be around for a
couple decades because of a change that
the Internet has wrought and so you're
part of that process tonight I'm wearing
the yellow hat as an indication these
are the people who collect your
questions they'll bring them up to me
and Kevin Kelley in the front and it's
gonna be an editor fest will Hearst as
an editor Chris Anderson's an editor I'm
an editor Kevin Kelly's an editor that's
what we do Chris Anderson it's yours
[Applause]
thank you and good evening what I'd like
to do first is run through about 20
minutes suggest a little a little
background and framing of what's the
long tail is what it means and then
changing dimensions looking from the
traditional concept of the long tail to
to the to the time version of it there's
going to be a lot of love charts and
data you don't have to pay attention to
it it's a lost rative the book the
research the article and most of my most
my thinking about this is all driven by
numbers we we live in we're very
fortunate to live in a moment where the
economics of the 21st century lie in the
server databases of Google and Yahoo and
Netflix and Amazon and if you only look
you can see extraordinary things and
surprising a few people are looking and
I've been fortunate enough to have their
cooperation and you'll see some of that
but we're just scratching the surface of
the really different economics culture
and lens on our culture lands on our
world around us that we can see out
there in these databases
it starts with numbers and this is this
is the sort of the shape of our age I
believe if it's called a power-law you
may know it also as a as Perret Oh
Wilfred Prieto was the Italian economist
who observed that that 20% of the
Italian population had 80% of the land
leading to the 8020 rule the notion that
a small number of things have a large
impact low frequency high amplitude
events earthquakes are distributed in
power laws a small number of big
earthquakes on a large number of small
ones populations cities distribute in
power laws a small number of very big
cities and large number of small ones
the shape is kind of a 1 over X it's
it's an exponential it's the simplest
possible curve and yet it turns out to
be absolutely Piqua tiss in
human affairs economies and nature
itself if you plot a power law linearly
it looks like that with you know a small
number of things on the left high
impacts and a large number of things on
the right it happens to go on forever
I've cut it off I've truncated it at a
random number if you plot it log log
which is to say that each each each axis
now comes an or factors of ten you
should get a straight line
sometimes a line the slope of the line
doesn't matter it depends on on the
market it depends on the circumstances
it depends on the units you're using but
it should be a straight line unless it's
not this is us box-office over a
three-year period the box-office gross
is on the Left exponential and in a log
scale and the ranking the film's the
number one film which did several
hundred million dollars all the way down
to about fifteen hundred films something
happens right I don't know that you can
see this little line but something
happens right there and what happens
right there is really interesting
because it sort of tells you everything
you need to know about about the
distortions of the last century in our
economy and and culture what happens
right there is not that the films got
worse
they didn't switch into foreign
languages they didn't stop making films
what happened is they ran out of screens
the carrying capacity of the American
theatrical network mostly the the big
screen mega plexus is about a hundred
and twenty films a year however the
number of films shown in film festivals
is closer to thirteen thousand the vast
majority of films never make it to the
megaplex they never get out there
they're just there there are not enough
screens to show all the films and so as
a result you end up with this distortion
you end up with the with the the
marketplace apparently falling off the
cliff not because people didn't want
those films not because they didn't
exist not because the films weren't good
but because of a scarcity effected
bottleneck in distribution and so in a
sense everything we think about to the
extent that we thought that Hollywood
represented American taste to the extent
that we thought that hits
the sort of we're what our society
collective society wanted it turns out
that in fact hits are what this the
distribution channel wanted it only had
so much shelf space and so two four
channels of television four radio
channels for retail shelf space every
one of these traditional ways of
distributing content where I started my
research um has a scarcity affection
every one of those scarcity effects
every one of those bottlenecks ends up
distorting the market and by extension
distorting our culture in a sense it
looks like this there is the same power
law and yet it just gets hacked off
truncated but now we're entering an era
where you have distribution methods that
don't have scarcity functions or at
least their mother pushed much further
down the internet has infinite channels
and infinite screens and infinite shelf
space
um and so what what you realize is when
you go back to that that line you
realize this pink bit right here is the
latent market that we were missing
before because we couldn't reach those
products because we couldn't connect
supply and demand and that right there
is the market we're just now starting to
explore and it turns out to be
remarkably large here's some actual data
from from Rhapsody which is a
subscription online music service it
benefits from unlimited shelf space what
you have here in the red part is the the
albums and songs that are available in
Walmart which is America's largest CD
retailer it has about 4500 albums in the
average Walmart so these are the hits
and these little these are the albums
that Walmart has and Rhapsody has down
here in the yellow these are the niches
these are the album's tracks and other
songs that Walmart doesn't carry but
Rhapsody does what's notable about this
is that although through some
complicated math involving you know
converting albums to tracks I Chi ID I
calculated the that the Walmart
inventory is about equal to 25,000
tracks Rhapsody right now carries 1.5
million
iTunes cares about two million tracks
the peer-to-peer networks are looking at
about nine million tracks there's
probably 25 million tracks out there
somewhere and vinyl live remix all the
other songs that are out there and could
be and will be brought online another
way of looking at it is right here
this is Walmart's inventory and this is
Ramsay's inventory we what we've thought
was the sort of the music market was a
tiny tiny fraction of the music market
in fact you know we're looking at order
of magnitude increase in inventory and
variety and so two four DVDs
blockbusters the average blockbuster
carries 3,000 DVDs Netflix is that
actually 60,000 right now over here at
Amazon the typical Barnes & Noble or
borders carries about a hundred thousand
books Amazon's now tracking three point
seven there's probably another another
six million books out there bring in the
network to use book you know stores
which are now sort of seamlessly
integrated into these online
marketplaces and you could be looking at
maybe as many as 10 million books in
various in various languages
extraordinary increase in variety and
what you find is that although we'd
assumed the retail channel said assume
that that that those niche low sellers
were insignificant sub-sub economic just
not worth caring in fact when you add
them all up those onesies and twosies
are starting to amount to significant
markets I mean in music they are closing
in on half the market is now stuff not
sold in Walmart in in at Netflix about a
quarter of the market a quarter of their
rentals or things that aren't available
in a blockbuster at Amazon's have also
about a quarter of the books now sold on
Amazon are books that aren't available
on the Barnes & Noble or borders all
those numbers are growing it looks like
we're trending to an era where about
half the market is sold through
traditional retail channels and the
other half of the market is is it's only
available through these sort of abundant
you know unlimited channels such as you
know with online in particular but also
things like like the u.s. mail another
powerful network is Netflix revealed so
let's talk about the time aspect of that
and there I've been talking about sort
of mainstream and niche
so blockbuster Tower Records Walmart
Borders they tend to carry the hits when
you have when shelf space runs it you
know they avert they get the cost of a
shelf space for one DVD is 22 dollars a
year in in Blockbuster you need to you
need a lot of turns you need it needs to
rent quite often to pay back at shelf
space so they have to carry the most
popular items so that's the way I looked
that's at the long tail hits to the left
niches to the right but there's another
way to look at it um when you think
about it as thing over time even hits
become small sellers even hits a you
know even even hits lose their their
traction in the marketplace and they
sell less and so the tail is actually
made up of a mix of some niche titles
and some old titles um for fun I thought
I would just show you two B's at the
BG's first album and this is broken
Social scene's
a new album called beehives this one was
a number one and now is ranked around
20,000 this started around 15,000 a very
niche title just if just just a year ago
and is now at around the same rank the
two of them are right next to each other
in the long tail but one's an old hit
and one's a new niche so we're mixing
these two markets together and they
obviously have different different
behavior so I thought I set out to
quantify this and what I like to show
you over the next few slides is really
just a work in progress as we try to
quantify the long tail of time so if you
tease apart if you cheese apart the Reds
and the blues you basically have two
dimension you have one that's sort of
its niche versus mainstream broad versus
narrow and the other new versus old both
have decay functions both both have a
power loss shape but so how do you how
do you combine the two well I realize
that there's sort of a topology here
that basically you hits hits here their
sales decline over time
well that's true for niche titles their
sales decline over time as well but
it's declined faster over time cuz they
got farther to fall Nisha's decline more
more slowly and that there's some shape
in there that will tell you a lot about
how to predict the you know the latent
demand in a marketplace so what is that
shape and how do we quantify it well
this is messy but that's research often
is um what we did is we looked at the
top 10 or the number-one albums for the
last the last ten years and we looked at
their current rating and so what we
assumed is then that the newer they were
the higher the rating would be they all
started at one and the new ones yeah the
one released this week is still one the
one released ten years ago has fallen to
some other level so we thought if we
scatter plotted it and then we could
sort of you know run a little run a
little you know sort of curve fitting
and see what they can get a shape and
you know sure enough but we can do more
rigorous work than that there is a
fantastic again we're very lucky to live
in a time where we're basically
everything is measurable someone out
there is tracking it all these servers
have all these data and increasing data
increasingly they're available there's a
service called info filter which kindly
let me in and we started tracking the
decay function of albums on Amazon
basically the sales rank goes goes goes
up as the sales decline so here is a
Arctic Monkeys which which made it to
here that was released right there and
obviously in pre-release and pre-sales
it went up the charts then a hit then it
peaked you know close to the day of
release and then it declined so that's
the decline function of an album that
hit number number two on the charts
mmm-hmm then I took a then we looked at
and other albums we've done these for
hundreds but this one is a a gospel
album also I'm also released around the
same time this one sort of started
number 500 and declined and now it's
announced about 1500 so a more gradual
decline a more gradual decay function so
going back to this original chart you
can see that we're starting to
if you wanted to in music you could
start to kind of have a sense of what
the Exponential's were what the what the
constants are to describe each one of
these curves this is this is important
and here and here's why
what do these five artists have in
common these five artists were five of
the top ten top grocers last year in the
music industry there is incredible
demand for older stuff some of it's
because it's good some of it's because
we're nostalgic some of it's because we
can get it um but these are just these
are just the hits each one of these did
more than 50 million dollars in business
last year but half of the top ten last
year were basically classic artists I
find odd that u2 is considered a classic
artist now by there there you have it
it's so that that's music I'm gonna now
plow through a couple of other examples
because that we can turn to the
interactive component with with will but
it's true for DVDs as well there's a
very interesting service called DVD
station and what it does is it takes a
it's got a box with a big hard drive a
terabyte drive and a DVD burner in it
and a screen and you can put it in any
store it could be a blockbuster it could
be just a corner grocery and you can
basically pick DVD to a little burn and
you can take it rent it you can bring it
back it it can have more inventory than
a blockbuster but it doesn't have to
what it does more importantly is it
makes it it alleviates of one of the
other problems of traditional retail
which is that's very hard to find things
you know in traditional retail this
store is set up for one size fits all
the new stuff is stacked hundred high in
the back the new the older stuff is
randomly put in some taxonomy that may
not make sense to you I remember looking
for a Kyra the Japanese anime is that
science fiction is it kids is it's
foreign is it is it's you know drama you
know what we're doin does it go and you
don't know and off the clerks can't help
you
what DVD station
by being a kiosk it allows you to have a
google-like functionality you can search
it has recommendations you can see
previews you can read in for more
information about it that's the two
limiting factors in traditional retail
are our inventory and findability i this
is an experiment in solving the
findability
problem it's interesting what you see
here so right here the or the purple
stuff represents the blockbuster sales
and the blue represents the DVD station
sales these are the same tracks but as
you see we're going on now over the same
DVDs rather but as you can see they're
getting older so here's the decay
function over time and what you see here
is that the older titles the older films
sell better are more popular when you
can find them maybe that stands to
reason and then you also see there's
this interesting structure right here
these are classics these are classics
that people love these are things that
have passed the test of time but have
been lost in the aisles lost in that
lost in the bins of a traditional
blockbuster but findable through a more
Google like interface and so what you
see is that the curve is flatter and
that and that there is strut there is
that the area under the curve is nonzero
this is this right here
five six seven years old this is the
this is the world the blockbuster
basically there economics doesn't allow
them to care about it but if you have
but if you have abundant economics where
you can carry everything you realize
that the demand is nonzero for instance
here's another way of looking at it this
is the demand for one year or older you
can see how much larger it is for the
kiosk google-like way of finding or
Amazon or Netflix way of finding it same
inventory just more demand for the older
tiles when you can get past the
findability hurdle what's interesting
about the old stuff is that the
economics which we assume we're worse
are actually better the reason is is
that the acquisition costs for DVDs have
a decay function as well a brand new DVD
costs about nineteen dollars to buy and
in Walmart is sold for about
dollars they lose money on DVDs
initially now it's a loss leader and
they make it been a they detract people
into the store with these cheap prices
and then sell them refrigerators over
time the acquisition cost comes down
dramatically in the in the fourth month
that's now down to fifteen dollars and
then right around here it becomes
profitable to sell and as you can see
the price the blue line declines
gradually whereas the cost the purple
line declines more rapidly and so the
commercials go from negative to very
positive over time so because the
because the acquisition costs are are
cheaper the older stuff is more
profitable interestingly it isn't just
more profitable it's actually more
satisfying Netflix did some analysis on
this Netflix also has the capacity to
have unlimited inventory and to
recommend and titles that you like based
on your your history and to give you
preview some samples and more
information what they find is that as I
just said the older titles have a lower
cost and so and so higher margins for
them but what they what surprised them
is that the satisfaction ratings were
much higher on the older titles and when
you think about it makes perfect sense
older titles have passed the test of
time they have the reviews have come in
word of mouth has spread people know
what they think newer titles the quality
of the title is overwhelmed by the
marketing in its first week what you're
seeing is is a huge flood of marketing
from the studios maybe you haven't read
the reviews maybe we hadn't had a chance
to talk to people maybe maybe you know
the sort of consensus view has not come
in and so you tend to just sort of you
know you're seduced by the marketing cuz
it works and what they found is that is
that the ratings on the new titles were
significantly lower than the ratings for
the old titles so when you think about
it blockbuster which because if it's
because of its need to stack them deep
and high and to push and the sort of
studio driven to economics to push the
new titles the most are in the place
where the movies cost the most and have
the lowest and return the lowest
satisfaction whereas Netflix is that
isn't the part where the movies in the
older films where they push they push
the man back over time
isn't the part of the market where the
movies cost the least and have the
highest satisfaction so Netflix is in
the sweet spot of the industry and
blockbuster is in the sour spot
simply because blockbusters driven by
the tyranny of the new Google is another
exam interesting example of this Wilson
the news for that was in the newspaper
business and I'm in the magazine
business and I can tell you that there's
the notion that you know that that the
new news is the important stuff and the
old stuff is fish wrap is pervasive
there was there was the presumption that
your front page is what matters its
freshness it's what's it's what's you
know right here now that is what's
popular but Google doesn't think that
way the way the Google algorithms work
is that there's a number of factors that
determine relevance but one of the most
important one is incoming links you know
the consensus view on how important
relevant and different content is older
stuff has longer time to build up
incoming links over time the relevance
the quality that sort of measured value
of older stuff Rises and Google actually
doesn't even the the spider doesn't even
get to the new stuff so Google almost
you know traditional Google obviously
they have Google's news and Google Blog
search but traditional Google won't even
know anything over the next over the
first 48 hours and then over time things
get more relevant not less so as we feed
as we see more and more of the traffic
to all of our sites driven by Google we
find that it's not going to the front
page traditionally it's not going to the
new stuff it's going to the old stuff
here's here's some data just from my
yeah I just reminders from our own sites
we find that 66 percent of the search
traffic is going to posts that are older
than one month old so two-thirds of it
and as a result this is just to just to
unpack this this is the new stuff here
this is the old stuff that comes from
search and this is the old stuff that
comes from links what you're finding
here is that this bit right there is
driving demand
this is the growing part here the stuff
that's coming from search and it is
traditionally and is just see 2/3 if it
is going to the old stuff this stuff
more than one month old as a result the
archives are suddenly becoming really
really important and you're seeing the
balance of the traffic growth going to
your old stuff this was this is
absolutely new and suddenly real it
makes you realize that that the
presumption that there was no value that
you barely had to leave him leave him
online you certainly didn't need to sell
ads against them is turning out to be
completely wrong we now realize that
quality doesn't disappear over time
instead this recognition increases I'll
give you a few other examples before we
before we end and turn to will the rise
of print on demand is a real driver
towards the back list in books I'm again
one of the problems with books is the
notion of shelf space the fact of the
inventory costs of stole is storing
books as significant
how would you store books with near zero
inventory though you store them as
digital files and you print them on
demand print on demand technology is
basically just a big photocopier but you
know today you'll buy books from Amazon
that I print on demand you don't know it
you cannot tell their color they have
they have proper covers they have charts
graphics
you can't tell they're not marked in any
way they just bought Google just by
sorry Amazon just bought a print on
demand company there's six of them
current being started just this year and
what's fantastic about this is it not
only allows you to take the older books
and rather than taking them out of print
just taking them to print on demand they
cost nothing to store you prints in
small batches sometimes as little as one
when required and the the price is a
little bit higher but not a lot higher
and the margins are positive because
there's no costs as it says it sits
there it doesn't gather dust it doesn't
exist in a sense till it's printed
what's what's important about this is
that and it not only allows them to
monetize these archives monetize the
back catalog but it also allows them to
smooth out demand at the front one of
the big problems with the book industry
is the notion of returns one of the
policies of books is that bookstores are
allowed to return new titles for free if
they don't sell
why would bookstores over order grossly
over order because they want to make
sure they don't run out if the costs are
borne by the publisher they might as
well over order and and you know and
pulp the rest send it back for credits
however there is a small cost because
those books have to sort of sit in their
warehouse the you know the book stores
warehouse so if they could avoid that
they would they just don't want to run
out well right now we print books in
batch big batches ten thousand twenty
thousand a hundred thousand but if you
could say well we're gonna you know
we're it's not gonna be sixty thousand
now and sixty months six two thousand
six months from now it could be sixty
thousand now and as much as you need
from now on we can get it to you in 24
hours we can print thirty forty we can
print three hundred can print three
thousand print on demand we can smooth
out the demand and you won't run out
then the book stores won't over order
and so a technology that was designed to
uh sort of unleash the value in the
archive is actually gonna have most of
his economic impact in smoothing out
demand at the head of the curve that's
that's a really important advance in an
industry that's struggling movie is
right now we're seeing the the rise of a
very very cheap DVDs DVDs again
especially through Amazon and Netflix is
a great way to distribute content
without shelf space constraints and
there is demand for television you're
seeing the rise of classic collections
which are again you know I Love Lucy or
anything else there is demand for this
some of its nostalgia so this is good
content DVDs are a great way to
distribute it one little note in our
analysis we have found that television
represents the biggest the biggest
divide between the amount of produced
content the amount of available content
the television model is one of just you
know produce it it exists ephemerally
its broadcast for a brief window and
then disappears the vast majority of
television isn't syndicated the vast
majority of television television hasn't
made its DVD vast majority of television
wasn't TiVoed it's just gone and yet it
exists out there and if you can clear
the rights which is something perhaps we
may talk about a little bit more will
you find that there is an appetite for
old TV if only you can get it out there
a final example I want to give you is is
gay
I'm a gamer and I grew up in the
generation that had the Nintendo and the
Atari and you know a lot of us uh you
know a lot of us think of this stuff
very fondly
however it's not available if you don't
have the original machine you can't you
can't play the games there's this notion
of abandoned where the manufacturers
actually not only don't sell them
anymore
but they won't let anyone else sell them
they don't want to support it and so
it's is they live in this netherworld
one of the reasons is that the retail
channels don't support um old games
their niche products they have a small
demand but very passionate Amanda but
there's a new distribution channel in
video games it's online marketplaces and
all three of the new consoles the the
Xbox 360 the Nintendo Wii and the Sony
Playstation 3 I'm all going to have
broadband distribution of games and
Nintendo in particular is building an
emulator for all of its old systems
right into the machine so every game
they've ever made will be playable on
the new machine distribution costs
inventory costs near zero there's demand
for this that we're finally able to tap
them so there's more of its in my book
which is coming out in in July but we
can get into further detail I think by
now turning to will who knows a lot
about this well
great talk Chris last time I saw you
talk on these subjects was down in d-day
oh and you've added a tremendous amount
of dimension so I guess the first thing
I want to do is maybe just slow the pace
down a little bit and go through some of
the things that you talked about but you
know let's start with there's two
dimensions of time that I'm particularly
interested in and and you've probably
done the best job I've ever seen of
quantifying these things so that we can
talk about some of these things in terms
of facts but the two dimensions that
interest me is one is sort of an
evolutionary process I think if you're
talking about time you're talking about
change in evolution and certainly in
this sort of large sphere of media
properties there are changes in
distribution changes in economics there
are some perpetual things and and I want
to come back to that assurance but
second but you do see these bottlenecks
and and I want I just like to sort of
think out loud with you a little bit but
looking at television let's take that is
the first example you know when I was a
kid there were basically three networks
and a bunch of other also ran local
independence so to speak and that was
the scope of television and seemed to
satisfy people but with the technology
that cable television brought into the
marketplace
starting with out of market and better
signals and people that had two of the
network's getting three but it very
rapidly became all 13 channels could
have content and then there was a
creative response to that and a kind of
marketplace evolutionary response
because all of a sudden we had MTV there
was nothing like that before we had CNN
we had discovery we had all kinds of new
content responses so I'm kind of
interested if the Internet has sort of
changed publishing and magazines were
changed maybe a decade earlier by
desktop publishing
you know there seems to be a kind of
evolutionary pattern when you blow open
the distribution change the cost of
entry you get a creative response so I
wondered if you had any thoughts about
as we blow open Internet distribution as
it moves up into video which is sort of
the way a lot of us get news for example
you know what what's your bet about the
let's start with the creative the
creative community response sure let's
just start with a show you one one one
one bit of data on this so we have a
precursor to the Internet which is in
the form of cable we started as you say
with for with terrestrial broadcast and
for networks and then as people got more
and more channels we started to see the
sort of the beginnings of an abundant
distribution and we now have I guess
nine hundred thousand channels um this
right here the the white line represents
the rise of what they call multi-channel
which is basically at cable and it's
basically knife I it's almost all all
homes now have cable and the black line
represents what that did to the
network's never share networks share
exactly and what we found out is that we
went from people watching the network
75% of the time back when they back when
there was fewer than half the homes had
had this sort of abundance of choice now
it's it's less than it's less than 50%
of the time spent watching the network
so what that means is that is that as
people you know in 1957 a 75% of
Americans watch I Love Lucy on ax on
American homes watch I Love Lucy on a
Sunday night it was even kind of the
peak of lockstep culture where we all
did the same thing at the same time the
peak of the water color water cooler era
now that we find more more more channels
more choice we find we're fragmenting
we're distributing across these many
many channels the modern equivalent of
that is YouTube or Google Video and you
know we've got now gone from 900
channels to an infinite number of
channels we've gone from commercial
content to skateboarding videos
uploaded we find that we've gone from a
kind of commercial a marketplace where
you know sort of you had to have a
commercial reason for making video to an
amateur marketplace where you don't need
any reason to make video because the
cost say everyone has a camcorder and
and the and distribution is free I think
what you're finding is two things first
of all you're finding that the the pool
of producers is expanding hugely because
we've democratized the tools of
production we've democratized the tools
of distribution so you know before you
needed to sort of have gotten into the
machine to get your stuff out now you
don't have to get to the machine you
know the machine is we all have we all
have the necessary tools you don't have
to be a member you don't have to be a
member of exactly and we're also finding
that the pool of viewers for this
content is also growing we assumed that
there was no demand for amateur
skateboarding videos we assumed wrong
you know we you know YouTube is is is
partly a reflection of you know pent up
demand for content not for commercial
content not distributed at you know at
the right time at the right channel sort
of a TiVo and the in the in the air and
partly demand for stuff that was never
commercial in the first place I think
it's I think we're seeing a renaissance
in in in culture we're seeing this
extraordinary explosion of of talent a
variety of choice of kind of cultural
richness that we'd only had some
glimpses of before and underground film
festivals and you know one-on-one
sharing now we can actually measure it
it turns out to be massive yeah I would
certainly agree and I think it's worth
mentioning that simultaneously there's
sort of an economic shift going on too
because in the first part in the
left-hand side of this diagram there was
kind of a near panic in the traditional
media corporate offices and in the
right-hand side which looks like the
disaster continues there's actually been
a sort of shift in the kind of
strategies of the big media companies so
where the NBC ABC CBS is of this firm
old were panic-struck in the left they
now own cable networks and and are
trying to reconstitute the economics by
sort of participating in the phenomenon
so this you know where this all goes is
interesting there is a kind of
consolidation afoot and it's not to my
way of thinking entirely accidental and
random that Fox is now the owner of
MySpace yeah there is a there is no sort
of economic second response you know
when railroads get to be too many pretty
soon you have consolidating yeah
railroads we could talk about why I
think I think about it
a sort of in slightly economic terms
that before I was at Wired I was at the
Economist so I'm sort of drilled in
economics you know we we see yep we now
see a huge expansion of supply oh and by
the way before ya go I want to also make
the point that while this looks like
some sort of declining business and you
know let's all diversify into gold and
oil in fact the media business during
the entire slide here has been you know
lower left to upper right in terms of
total dal it's remarkably a number of
people involved total economic dimension
of this phenomenon has actually gone up
with the fractionalization of audience
you know one of the one of the paradoxes
of our time is how the market share the
networks went down but the revenues went
up yeah every year the upfront every
year the advertisers pay more and more
for smaller and smaller audience they
had no choice now they now they do have
choices getting back to the economics we
basically have you know we have supply a
growing pool supply we had all the
commercial content both now both the
stuff made now and the stuff made all
overtime so there's that pool supply now
growing because of the democratization
of production and then you have this
demand all these people who wanted not
just what's being broadcast now but also
the stuff that's broadcast last week
last year ten years ago and all those
and the people who want all the stuff
that wasn't being broadcast at all but
we just couldn't measure it so a huge
expansion in supply and the huge
expansion demand so where's the problem
it's an
putting the two together now anybody any
you know any institution and often those
institutions are sort of broadcast
mechanisms that stands in between supply
and demand
is going to is going to run into trouble
foxes and interesting example is that
they're on the supply side they own
content they you know have the
relationship with the content producers
the affiliates are on there they're
they're the bottleneck what Steve Jobs
refers to as orifices right there is
some roadkill here there there is there
is indeed so so you know the people who
own the content and the people who can
sort of you know catalyze more content
want to find a way to reach all this new
new demand the problem is is that all as
you said all the money is coming through
these traditional channels how do you
match one might argue that the
affiliates who are getting killed who
are getting killed in this are really
not media businesses at all their
distributors its fans
yeah so I just escaped I just gave a
talk at the NA NAB the National
Association of Broadcasters and in Las
Vegas I'm about to decline of the hit
and I hadn't actually realized this is
the biggest television conference of the
year and I hadn't realized that the be
in broadcasting means terrestrial
broadcasting but that is and that the
best people there were radio engineers
who had a brilliant you know people who
basically built this you know built the
incredible communication systems we have
now but their their skillset is in sort
of tuning signals so they can go out
over them and I'm thinking you mean like
rabbit ears yeah and I like wow that's
that's that's the way viedo the industry
is still organized around remedy to a
lot of regulation that's based around
the ability for you to put up rabbit
ears and get a signal on you right
constitutional right to do that is a lot
of the screw eNOS of the regulatory
environment
another fractionalized media business
was magazines and I think we're both old
enough to remember life and look which
were the sort of networks of publishing
yeah and that business got creamed and
became special interest publishing but
something interesting happened out of
that which is the advertising
we're supported mass-market publishing
went away or went to television but
another kind of advertising that the
trout fishing advertiser that advertises
in the trout fishing magazine came in
and created a whole parallel industry
and I think in some ways Google Adsense
and the application of technology to
more rifle shot you know if we you know
what is an ad other than a link yeah
it's like a if you're interested in this
might you be interested in that and and
I think that's in its infancy to I don't
think the Google Adsense which is the
sort of holy grail of this thing is
really the you know miniature Holy Grail
because there's so much more that can be
done to try and be smart about I mean I
think Amazon's book finding and book
referencing engine which is based on
collaborative filtering is about ten
times more interesting than yeah Adsense
which tends to throw up stuff that
appears to be relevant but really isn't
I agree you know it's interesting we
think it you know an ad can be defined
as something you don't want
it's an interruption whereas something
but but but a marketing message that is
properly targeted is content and you
know often you find that especially just
magazine you take the ads the audience
is less interested that's right that's
right the suppository ads out of the
football game that's okay so these so
you know what's bid it's true
it's true and if you think about it you
know what's wrong with televising on
television is is the notion of sort of
keeping you from what you want by
forcing you to watch a message for
something you don't you want don't
intend to buy it's that's it but if the
problem is is that you've got a one size
fits all bucket you know you are willing
to broadcast the suppository to you know
100 million people to reach the two
million you actually and so it's o 94 so
here well it's worse than that
it's 90 that's wasted so you're willing
to annoy 98 percent of the population
and waste the money to reach that two
percent if you but if on the other hand
you could for example know who that
person was watching let's say you're
distributing the Superbowl now on the
Internet
and you slot the ads in based on what
your knowledge is of who the person is
how old they are where they live etc
then that goes to then rather you rather
than annoying people with ads they don't
want your actually give them things that
have much higher chance to be relevant I
mean there's attention here because I
think this is what's going to happen
mainly but I think there's a unintended
consequence that we're going to live in
a very monitored Big Brother kind of
world where people know more about you
than you maybe really want them to know
and while it's all presented as hey
we're here to help and I thought you
might like a code yeah there is a kind
of creepy quality to well knowing the
last hundred TV shows I watched that
that's true but there isn't I give that
information in Amazon by virtue of
surfing there exactly feels harmless but
what I think there's gonna be a choice I
mean I I think fundamentally you can
sort of opt in and and you and your
inclination to opt in will be based on
how relevant the ads are so you let
Amazon track your behavior because you
get value from it you know it's a net
it's a net positive because we probably
trust them on some level right but I
wouldn't want them to turn that over to
the Bush administration to figure out if
I'm reading the wrong kind of stuff are
you yes that's the cause of my concern
but but okay let's shift gears a little
bit because I want to try and mine this
time thing which again I've never really
seen anything like the quality of the
stuff that you've presented tonight but
the other sort of time dimension first
one is evolution change how media
changes and I do want to not I do want
to come back to that because I think
we're also at the infancy of sort of
figuring out what this new I mean we're
thinking of it as the new cheaper
distribution mechanism and enormous
impacts take place yeah if you go from
ten channels to 100 channels it's not a
very interesting technological change
but it's a gigantic creative change now
if you add something which is a genuine
technological change like interactivity
we're probably not doing a very good
I remember when I was working at the
newspaper when the personal computer
first came out the editor said to me
well we can't really run a story I said
well but people are buying it this is a
phenomenon yeah I can't do it you know
find out what's the application yeah so
I went around and we interviewed all the
people that I spoke to and I said what
are people gonna use computers for and
we came up with filing recipes and
writing your own Fortran programs right
so we didn't see desktop publishing we
didn't see we didn't even see word
processing never mind the internet or
email so I think we're in that kind of
early pre DW Griffith where we're
filming Broadway playing baby and
calling that a movie we haven't figured
out close up to the camera tracking
right that crap but we'll come back to
the head the thing I want to talk about
is the archival dimension because going
along parallel to your talk on this
decay of hits which is certainly quite
true is the loss of material yeah and
again I don't have an answer or a pitch
or or or like a fundraiser that I'm
doing but I feel that you know this
happens over and over again
most of the silent movies are gone yeah
you read about them and somebody tells
you this was a good picture you said
yeah you know I'm out of curiosity I'd
like to see it forget it it you know
when the people who have seen it die it
is gone it never took place and so you
know the you know the recognition that
there is value in the archives is just
the start how to extract that value is
really really tricky we should probably
talk about this for a few minutes cuz
there's a lot of dimensions to this the
questions begin to come up okay there is
there's a decay function over time there
should be you know as I said the decay
function tends to be a power law it
should be a straight line instead we you
know if you rather than do film rank
here if you just turn this axis here
into into age you find that you get this
also it's sort of plummeting effect this
pink bit right here is the is the value
of an archive that's untapped this is a
really important issue right now so as
you know MGM just sold
it's archived there are a whole bunch of
archives out there that everyone's
assuming they have X value and that x
value is based on our sort of existing
distribution mechanisms however if you
switch to abundant distribution systems
that value goes up we've been running a
kind of again you know it's not good
enough to publish but we've been running
an analysis where we look at sort of the
the sales of things over time the value
of an archive archive sales and then
draw a straight line and then calculate
what this thing here is and this this
amount right here is basically the
difference between what an archive has
currently valued at and what it would be
valued at in a perfect world if you're
out buying archives and there's a lot of
people who are and you do this analysis
and you realize that everyone is under
bidding and that you could bid more
because you can find a way to tap that
you would have a competitive advantage
and there's and there's a big big sort
of business school and private equity
exercise going on right now in trying to
do this analysis the reason it's a
little tricky is is basically three
things one is is is this the kind of a
format you know if it's in a you have to
digitize archives traditionally that's
that's costly
sometimes the its degraded and you can't
get to it
the second big issue is rights rights is
the elephant in the room of the longtail
you cannot clear the rights to old stuff
easily especially the music a famous
case is that a WKRP in Cincinnati which
was the 1970s possibilites a television
show that was set in a radio station
there is demand for WKRP in Cincinnati
out there and the problem is is that
throughout the entire show there's music
of the era playing in the background and
the cost clear all the music playing the
background at WKRP in Cincinnati is is
ruinous and it has become the sort of
the case study it is the hardest nut to
crack in all of television yeah and if
you can find a way to clear the rights
WKRP in Cincinnati you can clear the
rights to everything but we haven't yet
and so we don't know how to tell I would
imagine that the cost of clearing the
rights in 2006 is higher than the cost
of buying the right
when the show was made right they've
tried doing things like changing the
music um the problem is that people who
are really buying it for nostalgic
reasons remember the music and they're
like that's not WKRP in Cincinnati so
it's you know I you know the company
person legislature who can figure out
how to clear rights on industrial level
batch process really really efficiently
is gonna be able to transform this
industry you've probably talked to and
thought about Larry Lessig's views on
these subjects do you wanna well so yeah
this is interesting so let's Christmas
yeah I try not to do violence to Larry's
view Larry Lessig is the Stanford
University law professor who has been
opposing the extension of copyright
basically every year every 10 years
copyright gets extended another 10 years
this is largely to protect Disney's
properties Mickey Mouse and and and and
all that so exactly now Larry's view and
this is where I'm probably with slight
injustice to him Larry's view is that is
that older stuff doesn't have that much
value and therefore we don't need to
protect its rights 50 years 40 years of
copyright extension is enough and
anything beyond that that the the sort
of the the social benefit of getting it
out there so we can all use it much as
Disney used classic fairy tales that
were in public domain to build its
movies that there's a value and just
Lynne just freeing it up and at a
certain point you sort of say the value
has been extracted the you know there
the money has been has been you know
certain sir made on this property and
there's a social benefit letting it out
I am very sympathetic to this point if
you except for the fact that it runs
squarely against the long tail the long
tail says in fact there is value in the
archive that that we've been under
estimating the you know the demand for
old stuff not overestimating it and that
if you could only free it up you would
find that it has economic value not just
cultural value so I think this is a way
to square these two and one of them and
and and the problem with copyright law
right now is that automatically is
conferred it's automatically extended
whether people want it to or not
um what Larry has rec has suggested and
others is this sort of a de minimis
one dollar renewal you basically had to
put up your hand and say yes please
that's all you need to do a penny a
penny renewal and simply just saying
please renew it that's enough
you know you cared enough to Stu to have
it renewed the presumption is is that
99% of the stuff that actually no one
wants it renewed in fact maybe they
maybe didn't want the copyright
protection in the first place it wasn't
intended to add that kind of protection
and that most content would then fall
into the public domain
simply because no one cared enough to to
extend it yeah it's a very mixed picture
here I mean leaving aside maybe the
important question of social policy yeah
but I think economically Larry is wrong
there's lots of examples of archives
becoming more valuable you know you
mentioned the MGM case that was a
library that was sold twice it was
considered valueless sold to Ted Turner
he bought it for ten years when he
finished exploiting it was considered
valueless again and I was sold last year
to Comcast and Sony so it doesn't seem
to be going down no it's good and yet
the pictures are getting older and older
and they're black and white and so yeah
there's that problem then there's this
other oddball problem of old books you
know I mean I think we all have know
people or have friends who have
published a book that goes out of print
you cannot get the rights back as the
author and you know I that seems like a
tragic circumstance as well where the
rights are sort of it's kind of the
rights problem in another shape or guys
in the sense that something is
imprisoned
rights or imprisoned context act rather
than disappearing content exactly
books are a fascinating example the rise
of the secondary market in used books
has transformed the industry so you know
the traditional notion is that books go
out of print and then they're not
available but by simply networking all
the used bookstores and basically
allowing them so having them type in
their inventory and then collect an
inventory a single place a libres is one
company it's a local company that does
this but Amazon lists use books right
next to the the new books basically it
has create a liquid market and use books
you know that that makes it so that
nothing ever goes out of print if it's
if it's not available at the top-line
buy it new is available the next line
buy it used you know the
is often in sort of similar condition
and I'm the only differences that the
author doesn't get any money from it
when you buy it used it's your you know
you pay the used bookstore but nothing
goes back to the author and this notion
of reselling old books yeah is is great
for our culture and for us as consumers
that we now sort of out of print is out
of fashion out of print is no longer
meaningful um but it doesn't solve the
problem from the author's perspective
and a you're right it's hard for them to
get back the rights and sometimes they
don't even want to this is an
interesting thing sometimes they don't
even want to switch to print on demand
because print on demand books tend to be
more expensive than the new books and a
lot of authors say if you make me a
print on demand book you're gonna keep
the book you're gonna keep it as a cut
in your catalog it's now gonna cost
twice or you know 50% more than it used
to cost and I'm not gonna get and my
sales aren't gonna go up if you would
give it back to me I would you know talk
to a more you know creative publisher
and they would fly they would market it
and they would give it the audience it
deserves and you you by turning into a
print on demand book are actually
ruining my market and it's a debate not
yet solved I don't know about the dollar
to renew but I do think there ought to
be some sort of principle in law that if
I bought the rights to something and I
owned them and I tie them up and I'm
supposed to be economically exploiting
them yeah and I'm not doing that then I
think they should revert it should be
okay you did your time's up you have to
either keep paying me and keep I mean I
what I hate to see is that FileMaker
makes a movie struggles to get the thing
funded and then can't hang on to any
rights because in order to get the
theatrical release you've got to give up
rights and the contracts read on any
planet and universe known or unknown
technology invented or not invented or I
mean these are incredibly broad waivers
of rights and you know great if you want
to exploit the rights to print my book
on frisbees great but then print it on
Frizzle well I think one thing we can be
sure of is that Congress will not solve
this problem so I think it's a great
opportunity right now I think this is an
entrepreneurial opportunity we're in the
right place for people to think of
creative ways to route around this
problem offering economics and
incentives technological abilities
demonstrate the demand out there so that
the owners
these rights the people who are keeping
these these sort of valuable cultural
commodities locked up in warehouses see
the opportunity see the rate of the way
and the reason to get it out there okay
well I'm gonna dive into the questions
here because they're building up I'm not
sure I've done a good job of organizing
them but let's just dive in question not
all nish Content decays in popularity
some grow out of the niche and become
more popular as they get older how do
you spot these sleeper hits in the long
tail yeah this is this is a great
question actually the the opening
anecdote in my in my article and still
appears somewhere in the book is there
is they as a book called touching the
void it's about a mountain climbing
tragedy and the book came out in the 80s
and it was sort of you know modestly
successful and then as books tend to do
sort of fell off the the cliff and was
eventually serve destined to go out of
print and then Jon Krakauer released
touching the boy I'm sorry into thin air
which was another big hit and people
said you know this there's a book a lot
like this book as I remember and they
sort of you know they sort of you know
mention didn't someone said did a little
work and found it and wrote about in the
reviews and in into thin air and people
checked it out it's like it's fantastic
and they rediscovered the book and then
and two years later touching the board
was out selling into thin air you see
this often when someone dies for example
you often see their body of work becomes
more popular when and when an actor
releases a new movie the old movie the
old movies by that actor become more
popular so there's always opportunities
for confluence of events or sort of
increase in celebrity can derive demand
back into the catalog it's a funny point
you're absolutely right there are when
you see a movie star die you'll see a
spike in the DVD rentals of their titles
it's just right there like a here's a
question from Kevin Kelly Chris are you
suggesting that technology does not
change the power law only exploits it
more fully does that mean is the shape
of the curve will be the same
years once we have access to infinite
shelf space is that the end of history
is it possible technology can alter the
power curve itself in the long term I
think I think Kevin is is not asking the
the you know the question sounds like
which is like does the shape say exactly
the same obviously as the tale grows the
curve becomes a little flatter it's
still a power-law
but it's not quite as steep the hits
aren't quite the ratio between hits and
Nisha's is you know sort of evens a
little bit but that I think he's
actually actually asking another
question which is that does do we stop
having power laws altogether to actually
go to a sort of straight a straight line
of demand yeah Kevin EMI is that what
you're asking I think the answer is no
and let me explain a y3 explaining why I
think that so three factors make a cut
power law you need to have you need to
have variety so lots of different things
inequality some things depending on you
or whatever your measure is some things
better than the others and then
something that economist called network
effects and you can think of that as
word as word-of-mouth when you have
variety and inequality the network
effects identify the sort of the buzzy
ones and they get and network effects
amplify signals so you know sort of
word-of-mouth amplifies the good intends
to suppress the bad so what you're
seeing here is is is that this the
steepness is what Network effects do it
amplifies this side and suppresses that
side I think as long as you have network
effects you're always going to have
you're always going to have a power loss
shape Network effects tend to amplify
inequality so if you have variety and
inequality as long as you have network
effects you won't get straight lines but
will instead get Exponential's one of
the things that I hadn't I hadn't
noticed this the first time I saw your
talk is that is that this power law sort
of persists well out to a certain sort
of zone the the bathysphere and then it
kind of drops off and and you relate
that to shelf space scarcity affects
about various sorts so I mean it sounds
like you are saying that with the growth
of shelf space that drop-off point
moves yeah you know the curve clings to
the power law longer before it falls
into the the merely irrelevant let me
show you another piece of data this is a
little bit naughty since this hasn't
been published yet but let me see if oh
I'm sorry I didn't mean to bring up my
kids sorry kids okay I'm not gonna pull
it up isn't too embarrassing
I was gonna I was gonna I was going to
show the the Netflix data the Netflix
data also also does does this but it
doesn't much much further out and you
know we thought about this why is that
so Netflix has infinite shelf space it
has excellent findability so what the G
the to usual skill is scarcity effects
are and we do this in business goals by
the way we look at we look at data and
we sort of say okay you business school
students are about to graduate and go
into the world and start new companies
that's where you start a company right
there is the scarcity effect if you can
eliminate that scarcity fact you just
you move the curve back onto the
straight a straight line so what is that
and so in some cases that shelf space in
other cases it's that search problem
it's that it's the transaction cost of
finding something but Netflix doesn't
have that Netflix has great findability
great a great shelf space and yet it too
falls off at around at around the last
five thousand titles fall off we think
and I don't know this but we think
they're a foreign language we think that
you actually have a little sort of
scarcity effect in English well one
thing that I think I would argue is a
permanent feature is that there will be
a left side of the power curve I don't
think there will be an equi distributed
sort of curve even with infinite and
beyond
shelf space because there's sort of a
need in the world for Super Bowls and
these occasional events there are
products like Coke right that need those
events and there are maybe some tribal
things that we need to do all in the
same day
fewer and fewer smaller percentage of
our lives but occasionally we need those
I totally agree holidays and
years and elections and yeah things that
sort of connect the tribe together for a
while I agree entirely I mean one of the
big sort of misunderstandings the long
tail is that's the end of hits and the
sort of you know the the the BIC WA T of
Nicias in fact it's just it's just this
sort of the end of the tyranny of hit
and it's now you're going to have a kind
of a balanced market between hits and
niches you know we're gregarious species
we'd like to do things that other people
are doing but we're not as gregarious as
you know the the sort of hit driven
economy the last hundred years suggested
that amplified the gregariousness some
of those seventy-five percent of
American homes really did want to watch
I Love Lucy and some of them watch
because was the only thing on and that's
and that that's that other part my bed
and I guess if I really was serious
about it steward would make me sign up
for one of his long bets but my bet is
that in fifty years they'll still be
seven studios they'll still be a handful
of corporate entities that are trying to
make hits yeah even though they may have
vanishingly small percentage of the
total audience there was going to be a
need for that part of the ecosystem let
me let me I can't pull up something that
will speak to that precisely some music
is music is a is a fascinating industry
we've been looking at it closely because
it's it's it's really sort of the canary
in the coal mined this is this is how we
measure hit some gold records 501
million and multi million look at that
mm now it turns out that in sync second
album no-strings-attached released on
March twenty first two thousand was the
high-water mark of the blockbuster
century notable note it's very poignant
it's the first day of spring of the new
century it was five days after the
Nasdaq crash it launched Justin
Timberlake's career and and and it was a
it sold a 2.4 million copies in its
first week a number I believe will never
be passed they will never again be an
album as big as no strings get rid of
bad I guess the other thing I would say
is I do
thinking sort of thinking about Kevin's
question one more time that there is a
different sort of physics working on the
curve when you get in to millions of
channels then these promotion problems
my partner John Doerr is fond of saying
that every great internet business has
been based on finding a needle in a
haystack yeah but these search problems
and what the filmmaker tends to think of
as the promotion problem
I interviewed Paul Kagan many years ago
and sort of pre-visualized with him this
world where the filmmaker and the film
viewer would connect together and he
said you know this is sort of a Silicon
Valley fantasy that all it really takes
is somebody with a story and somebody
else that wants to hear it but there's a
middle piece we'll called promotion and
that's what the studio's really do know
it's not just distribution it's not just
funding production there's this hoopla
element yeah when you get to a million
titles I don't think you can do it by
buying television you can't access so
social networking to some extent is
becoming the when a new way in which we
can automate word-of-mouth and we can
provide sort of new generation promotion
I mean if you ask Reed Hastings the CEO
of Netflix what the most important thing
about Netflix is he won't say it's you
know infinite variety or you know
unlimited unlimited rentals or no late
fees he says it is the marketing power
of recommendations when you think about
it it costs Netflix absolutely nothing
to recommend a title to you
it's teacher it sees what other people
liked it sees what you've rented in the
past and it reconfigures it's it's
storefront as it were to give you
something that you think's you'll like
that has all the power of advertising
it's just like marketing it's the same
effective marketing but it doesn't cost
anything and the notion of zero cost
marketing is the is the silver bullet
you know for for films you almost needed
because I mean
the long the longer part of the tail
chokes if you don't find some way to
find things I mean this is what you know
Google came along its sort of the right
moment when it when the traditional
search engines weren't doing very well I
have a close friend of mine in Silicon
Valley who came up with the idea for a
pre Google company okay here's what
we'll do we'll let people buy their way
up the relevance ranking yeah and this
had the effect of sort of polluting the
quality of the search results and Google
sort of arrived on the scene and said
we're not going to do that we're gonna
have an ad edit separation what what an
amazing novel idea but I mean I wouldn't
really want to read the New York Times
reviews of movies if I thought the
number of stars correlated to the ad
budget of the studio that made the movie
and this is what was happening in the
internet but you do have these these
problems when you go to a million titles
you've got to have an honest way to to
find things and to be recommended things
absolutely it's yeah I think the
marketplace solves this one but I mean
just just to your to your point about
movies here I want to show you one one
you know you think of this as being the
golden arrow the blockbuster but the
portion of of the total revenues that
are blockbusters is falling and the cost
which is mostly the marketing costs and
the stand paying the stars is rising the
television graph moved over this is you
know even even Hollywood which we
thought was the last remaining
blockbuster industry the wheels are
starting to fall off there too right and
this year is eight as you know a box
office was the worst year I guess worse
fall in 20 years last year and I think
there are more film festivals today
there's sort of one or two every night
of the year as opposed to a handful of
festivals so we're okay let's do a
better job on questions can you relate
the long tail to the current trend on
the supply side where consumers are
becoming creators oh absolutely I mean
this is this is you know I mean again
the the YouTube phenomenon myspace
Wikipedia the blogosphere this is what I
when I talk about the democratization of
production the democratization
distribution you know we're talking
about blogs we're talking about about
upload
you know videos of yourself lip-syncing
they're the most popular ones I you know
I I bang on a lot about this this sort
of elitism that we've had that
professionals produce yes professionals
produced and the reason the
professionals produced is because they
because only they had the keys to the to
you know to the to the machine do they
you know the machine you know they you
the notion that you know you needed a
printing press to be a publisher every
blogger right now has a printing press
and everybody who has a you know a
broadband connection has access to a
video distribution network that rivals
you know the biggest the biggest studios
in terms of its reach so I think that
you know that you're seeing the rise of
kind of mass amateurism you know the
rise you know we've had this assumption
the talent is sort of you know scarce
and that you need this sort of big
filtering you know process to identify
you know the good people let them into
the Machine it turns out the talented
talent is very widely distributed and
far more widely distributed than our to
then our distribution you know
institutions and something like YouTube
something like Wikipedia is something
like the blogosphere suddenly allow
silent to identify itself and then all
those network effects of just sort of
you know we're very very good its
spotting stuff and bring it to the
attention of others with rule inks
through Google and everything else we're
now starting to find out just how rich
our culture is in terms of talent and in
variety as well you're seeing stuff that
isn't just as good as the stuff that was
commercially produced but never would
have been produced just to kind of
become coming from left field yeah it's
a very interesting moment thinking of
television for a second to television
news basically doesn't exist today
because what we're seeing I mean there
are reporters maybe in San Francisco
covering San Francisco stories or at
least holding a camera up in front of a
San Francisco story but yes the
international news which used to have I
mean I'm gonna make a slightly retro
point here but in the era of twenty
years ago there was a notion of a
professional journalist I'm not saying
let's race back to that era what I'm
saying is that notion is utterly gone
and what we are seeing as so-called
profession journalism is really
freelance material shot and Baghdad
shipped to new you are somebody
voiceovers it and and that's supposed to
be live news yeah and and we're covering
Israel out of London we're covering
Nairobi out of Tokyo
you know we're kidding ourselves so in a
way I think the cure is not to go
backwards but to go forwards and to get
and to label that stuff and get more of
that material and kind of do away with
this pseudo professional news which it
really isn't yeah I mean if we're gonna
have citizen journalism then let's let's
have it I mean I I guess I you know I
feel very conflicted about this I mean
you know on with one hat I'm I mean a
Conde Nast editor you know the very sort
of you know sort of it's sort of the
embodiment of the old style of you know
sort of elite you know premiere big
production process in our journalism on
the other side I'm a blogger my peers
and the blogosphere are are any one of
you they're engineers they're they're
they're students they're retired people
they I don't care we've decreed n
children initialized journalism might
the people I respect the most of the
people have something to say who have
sort of you know who have unique
information unique perspective unique
articulation yeah and I don't care what
their affiliation is whereas the
journalistic model was you needed at the
press card you needed to have that
association to be respected at the risk
of going down the wrong path
my concern simultaneous and and on the
same topic is I'm concerned that what we
now call journals and I'm thinking of
television maybe more he's really just
opinion mongering so Fox gets a bunch of
guys up to talk about the news none of
whom are eyewitnesses to anything yeah
and then another network gets up another
but you know macneil-lehrer gets a
conservative to argue with an
arch-conservative over some point and
neither one of these people is you know
a principal is an it's not an actual
interview it's it's a tertiary news
event and you know great but but to me
the
these are just you know bloggers that
get airtime yeah you know there is such
a thing as an eyewitness reporter there
is such a thing is getting the facts
straight that's not the same thing as
saying objectivity rules and opinion is
worth noting but there there is some
difference between hey I was there this
is what I saw and oh yes I'm an expert
on that subject let me tell you that
what the correct view point is to have I
think you're exactly right I think
here's the good news
I think the marketplace is going to sort
this this out you know once upon a time
if there are only so many channels you
know there was kind of a social
responsibility for those channels to be
good to be responsible
now there's an infinite number channels
if they suck they're gonna be replaced
by somebody who's doing it bad well I
bring it on and that is a little bit
like this question because this is kind
of a gotta go one way or the other
question does the fractionalization of
channels in all media types does that
does it portend a better higher quality
of social evolution due to more
experimentation or a lower quality due
to the lack of cohesion and cooperation
and it's a great question this is the
whole kind of you know sort of is a
vulcanized culture a good culture I have
a chapter on this in the book
unsurprisingly I I think that it's a net
positive I think what I think is that
we're going from an era where we've been
sort of because of the incredible
powerful broadcast technology which
broadcast is a great way to sort of
reach a lot of people with a small
amount amount of stuff I think that our
linkages to the extent we've been
watching the same things at the same
time listening the same things at the
same time we have sort of we have served
very very wide but shallow links with
each other you know the fact we both
watched I Love Lucy is not really a very
strong you know connective tissue
between us now we're not we now it was
that those those weak links are breaking
instead what we're doing is we're having
more tribal culture where what I do is I
find my passions and I can pursue them
to the ends of the world and I can find
people who share my passions and so now
I have a smaller number of tighter
connections so I think that I think
we've gone from you know sort of get
right on some level you know we as a
nation are not one are not one sort of
you know lockstep culture but I think
what we've discovered is that within our
within our country has been a has been a
sort of a you know a depth and a variety
that was suppressed by the brother by
the economics and physics of broadcast
and we're discovering that we do have
these passions that we share with people
who aren't around us but we can find
them elsewhere what this does to you
know to to politics what this does to
our sense of being an American what the
sense of does to whether our sense of
being part of our time we don't know yet
I think it's gonna it's going to evolve
but I'm optimistic that that bit tighter
but fewer connections are probably going
to be a net positive yeah and I you know
I'll just chime in behind you because I
think in terms of my own taste I really
prefer to be disagreed with I learn more
that way I don't really want to be in a
culture where everybody is like me and
we all agree and we're right you know it
just seems icky awful okay question from
mark it could be argued that current
classics benefited from the marketing
forces of their era to ever become or be
deemed a classic how do you think the
long tail effects the factors that
determine what is a classic in the
future yeah it's not just as simple as
quality will trump hype is there more to
you know I think it might be simple as
that actually you know if you go back
and I mean is an interesting exercise I
wish I had the chart here but if you go
back and look at the Academy Award
winners or even the number one out of
one number one films from the 40s 50s
and 60s it's amazing how many you've
never heard of they just disappeared
they were the like the biggest film of
their day and they're gone um and yet
some of the films from those days aren't
gone so I think the time does actually
you know time plus quality allows you
know the winners to do to to rise well I
do think the time thing and it's
illustrated by your quantitative stuff
but I do think you know you're talking
about the sort of random quality of a
something that's being promoted as a hit
yeah and it maybe it becomes hit maybe
it doesn't but the promotion
sounds pretty the actual experience is a
little more random now when the thing is
20 years old
it may be for me or it may not be for me
but I pretty much know what yeah I know
what a John Wayne movie is yeah it's not
like what is that and so I think there's
a sort of relaxation effect that is
underlying some of the numbers that you
talked about where it becomes sort of
located and maybe changes over time
slowly but you know it's a known thing
which is why there is a satisfaction
because I don't get accidental stuff I
know what I'm looking for exactly he I'm
able to find it exactly I think you know
being able to see past the marketing
blitz actually reveals the true the true
characteristics of the of the product
you know as determined by the wisdom of
the crowd okay let's we have at least
two more questions the longtail although
formerly truncated is now open for
business this presumably means many more
fringe concepts once excluded from the
big screens are now accessible to us all
what do you think are the political
implications yeah you answer that one
I'm in a sour mood about politics
because I worry a lot that we're
becoming an opinion acqua see and I and
I am a little bit on a soapbox that that
I enjoy that I'm a participant I'm a
consumer of it but I I like your I
occasionally I can be refreshed by
somebody with facts and numbers and and
you know I was kind of tricked into
believing in this scientific method that
we could disagree but we might reach a
proposition that we could then sort of
settle by the facts and we could we
could make a bet and one of us would win
and one of us would lose and I would
hate to see the sort of everything is
equal and everything is relative and
objectivity doesn't exist
become a hey you know opinion Trump's
reality so that's my little soapbox
about yeah the the sort of momentary
degradation of political discourse as
we're democratizing and opening things
up I I agree I mean I'll hazard a kind
of a structural theory about what might
happen with politics
maybe the two-party system is a scarcity
effect um maybe it's that maybe it's
that we just don't have a way to tap the
diversity of opinions the diversity of
views that we have and we have to we
have to collapse this kind of
distributed function into this to hump a
function because we don't have a better
a better way I don't know exactly what
that better way is I don't know as
direct democracy or just sort of more
efficient spreading of messages or
better representative democracy I don't
know what the answer is but I I the
trends suggest that we as a population
are more diverse than just two polls so
why don't I can hope this may be the
last question then we have to weigh in
Chris finished how does how do the
editorial roles change as the
distribution bottleneck opens up as
editors how do you feel about these
shifts any ideas on the future of
editors in new and news and products and
and is this good or bad for consumers
yeah this is a great ones they say I'm
hugely conflicted about all these things
i-i-i-i talk about the the notion of
pre-filters and post filters and I'm
going to try this is always risky to
mess around with PowerPoint on stage we
are editors job is to be the you know
exactly what the long tail advises
against we we decide what gets out there
our job is to guess at what's going to
be popular we have limits
pages limited number of channels limited
number of time and so we try to guess at
what people are gonna want and we then
and and we then predict the demand and
we try to get it out there so we're you
know the the whole notion of the long
tail is that this is the wrong way to do
it rather than predicting demand rather
than trying to guess at what people want
to what you do she let it all out there
and the marketplace sorts it out you
know YouTube no one there's no editor
for YouTube who services it you know
that's not gonna be popular we're not
gonna put it out there
I mean said it gets out there and and
you know the viewers decide what's what
what's popular so so here so these are
these are kind of the pre-filters we as
we as editors you know are keeping stuff
keeping keeping stuff away from people
that's what our job is studio executives
you know saying know that their job is
to red light things we would think about
the green lights but most of what they
do is red lights this department store
buyers their job is to sort of try to
guess what people want whereas in the
longtail markets it all gets out there
because you have unlimited distribution
and and and and and after the fact post
facto the you know the you know we now
can measure what the people want rather
than guessing we measure so what's the
role of an editor in a world where the
marketplace can do our job for us and I
think I think this gets down to the the
notion of recommendations um I think the
job of an editor is is to be a annarbor
to have a sensibility and a taste and a
discrimination of quality they can sort
of point out the stuff that's out there
and say this is good that's good and
this is good Kevin Kevin Kelley has a
fantastic blog and newsletter where he
sort of identifies cool tools out there
he didn't decide which tools could get
out there he didn't make those tools
themselves what he does is he is he
anoints them as being cool and because
people on because kevin is a person and
people you have respect his taste and
and share his sensibility that that
editing role of identifying something as
cool becomes a hugely powerful driver to
demand and Kevin we may be able to speak
at what
what the Kelly effect is on sales but I
imagine it's not it's not trivial so
maybe that is the role of the editor is
to is to is to have a sensibility a very
server branded a branded personality a
branded sort of worldview and that to
then filter the great volume of good
stuff out there through this worldview
so that people who share that worldview
can find it yeah I I guess I think the
traditional editor in the sense of
gatekeeper is finished I don't think
there will ever be in in this kind of
culture this kind of communications
culture we've crossed some threshold and
I think the traditional dare I say it's
sort of her ste and model yet somebody
that can make someone a king or ruin
somebody I think that's really just
finished yeah it just isn't going to
exist anymore I do agree with you that I
know people and and and maybe we all
know people who have great taste and
whose movie recommendations are
remarkably good but even critics I think
have lost some of their power right I
mean I'm interested in critics now more
because they write well yeah because
they think like I do and I'm not gonna
go to a restaurant or not go to a movie
or read a book or not read a book
because some critic tells me I should or
shouldn't do this it's just finished
yeah
there are also are other sort of
mechanisms of sort of emergent behavior
reinforcement I'm almost done
where I find that if you a friend of
mine has a website that where people
sort of pick interesting videos on the
net yeah and all he all he has to do is
show people whose pics are liked by
other people he doesn't even have to
tell you why these pics are good or what
method this person uses but the
community says oh that's how you become
a well-read blogger okay III think I
know what's going on and and they they
almost model the behavior without an
editor sort of saying this is
interesting and that's not it it almost
it's not even a a kind of
democratization it's an emergent
behavior either
community and then the last thing I
would say is I think editors might still
exist as coaches yeah I mean I still
think it's fun to work with a young
writer help them become better suggest
an idea hey read this book this is the
kind of writing that is reminds me of
what you're trying to do that part of
editing still exists but the gatekeeping
part is finito
I'll finished with just one little irony
my book on the rise of nation being is
been published by Disney just Disney's
book superior Hyperion is is my
publisher I didn't need them for
distribution I didn't need them for
production I needed them for advice they
they made it a better book they edited
they did what editors used to do which
is make things better and you know I
think that's that maybe their role going
forward right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you